so my name is Dan Ariely I'm the James B
Duke professor of behavioral economics
and author of predictably irrational
so first of all it's kind of interesting
that saving patterns have changed since
the market tragedy of 2008 but if we
talk about early early on what was
happening in the US and the reason for
not saving is the same reason for not
doing all kinds of other things right we
don't exercise we don't eat healthy we
have unprotected sex I mean there's lots
of things like it and the big issue is
that we have one thing that we want one
now and another thing we want in the
future and when we focus on this
trade-off between now in the future it's
very hard to focus on the future
so think about eating healthy you've
vowed to be on a diet you go to a
restaurant the waiter comes with the
chocolate souffle right you have a
long-term wish to be good but you have
this short-term desire to consume this
chocolate souffle and the short-term
desire often wins we have a long-term
desire not to procrastinate I mean
there's lots of things like it so that's
kind of the basic the basic story of
lots of things that we delay now money
actually becomes even more difficult
than other things because it's very hard
to imagine what are the benefits for
saving so imagine that you see a new
bicycle or pair of shoes or something
today you know exactly what you're
giving up if you're not buying it what
are you gaining in the future if you're
not getting it so you're giving up a
bicycle today what is it in the future
what will happen if you send another
thousand dollar to your retirement fund
what what what difference will make it's
very very hard to figure out and on top
of that I also think that the banks have
been doing a very bad job so you know
when you don't go to these retirement
experts they ask you two stupid
questions
the first stupid question is how much of
your salary now will you need in
retirement how are you supposed to have
an answer for this oh this question I
know the answer very well right what
what's the right answer for this very
hard to figure out the second stupid
question is what's your risk attitude
and we actually know that depending on
what on people's mind at the moment they
can have high risk attitude and low risk
attitude nobody really knows what the
risk attitude is what does it really
mean so if I started talking to you
about how you felt in the last market
turmoil and how was it to feel one day
when you're a portfolio went down by 10%
you lost elderts money and then I asked
you what's your risk attitude you'll
tell me a very different answer than if
I ask you to tell me how much you enjoy
the Bahamas and how much do you want a
beach house and so on so the people in
the financial industry asked us these
two stupid question and then they go
ahead and spend millions and millions of
dollars optimizing based on these
ridiculous questions and and I'll tell
you kind of a sad story sometime ago I
was invited to the announcement of the
fidelity my plan calculator and they
basically had this unveiling about this
calculator and so on and it's an
unbelievably simple thing you basically
have 705 question I can't remember they
asked you and then at the end they tell
you you need to save 4.2 million dollars
now I can't say 4.2 million dollars it
just don't happen and nobody in that
industry is helping me figure out what
will happen if it's less what happened
if it's 3.5 what happens if is 2.1
nobody's helping me doing any of those
things so in fact the industry is also
not helping us in fact I think of saving
is running a marathon when nobody tells
you what's the end point and how far
your you've been going so lots and lots
of things make it difficult
so so the question is are Americans
different than other people and I think
in some sense we are and in some sense
we aren't I don't think we're different
people were wired the same way we're
very similar in fact most of the
research we do we show that people are
the same everywhere there are really
small differences where we are different
is in the social norms so you grow up in
another country and your parents tell
you little Johnny or a different name
depending on the country you when you
get a paycheck you save 30% of it you
save 25% of parents tell you what to do
there's almost a rule of what to do
that's not clearly the right approach
it's not really the right number to save
but parents tell you what you're
supposed to be doing in the US I think
there's an ideology of not telling kids
what to do and nobody to tell you who to
marry and I'll tell you what job to pick
your dairy your own person you have the
freedom to choose including the freedom
to fail in magnificent ways and I think
that's the big difference in other
countries that's basically a social norm
about saving but is passed from
generation to generation in the u.s.
there isn't now one of the other
interesting things that is happening is
what's happening now in terms of saving
and saving rates are increasing up now
quite quite dramatically and part of it
is because people have lost trust I mean
who would you trust right now which bank
would you trust which investment do you
trust do you really want to put your
money you want to suffer more of these
losses that we just had you know this
volatility that we see is just
unexplainable by any rational standards
nobody have any clue about how to
explain this and nobody want to
experience that so we hold more money
back we don't necessarily want to invest
in the market and by default people are
saving more now the interesting question
is well whether we will develop habits
of savings and I'm actually quite
optimistic about this because you know
if you think about people as making
decisions actively every time we think
about the cup of coffee we say how much
will I enjoy the cup of coffee
what else could I not do in the future
because I buy this cup of coffee these
are incredibly hard decisions so people
don't do them and instead they rely on
habits these habits fuel our decisions
even when the underlying causes are
irrelevant so one question about now is
what
people would start saving whether we get
to habit into this mostly because of
fear of putting money in the stock
market and actually they will keep on
doing it even when it's not necessarily
the greatest strategy in the world but
we'll develop a habit for doing so and
this is what happened for the Depression
era and I think it might happen now
again
well I'm not sure on anything but but I
think in the financial domain we
suffered a great blow to our trust into
a relationship with the financial system
look we had a very long run of about 25
years if you think about people who are
my age we never saw a market that was
not just getting better all the time all
of a sudden we got a big lesson about
what could actually be be happening so I
think there will be there will be a
lesson that will stay with us for a long
long time there's another question here
which is what will happen to consumption
there's something economy is called
positional goods positional good is
something that you don't care about how
much you have you just want more than
the other guy and there's an example
think about sea lions sea lions want to
be big because if they're big they get
more females so imagine all the sea
lions everybody is trying to get a
little bit bigger than the other person
that other sea lion and in the process
all the sea lions becoming so big that
then then die at an early age from all
kind of diseases and you can see the
metaphor for American consumption we
don't really want the huge house but you
want the house that is slightly bigger
than our neighbors and slightly cars
that are bigger than the neighbors going
Vickey that are slightly more expensive
and this escalation happens that things
can't get out of hand recently I went to
one of my kids birthday parties and you
know all the kids are there and there's
this float in a clown and this and sushi
for the adults and wine and cake and all
kinds of stuff is happening and one of
the parents came to me and said you know
I think we should scale down I think we
should all the parents agree to go down
have simple fun birthday parties now
this is exactly the problem the problem
is that the kids don't care what party
they have right they want cake and they
want to run around nothing else matters
but in this escalation all the kids want
parties like their friends so if all the
friends have an amazing you know
expensive parties they all want the same
thing if we all got to scale down is a
coordinated effort all the kids would
have been just as happy and I think
that's actually an interesting case of
whether there will be kind of social
mechanisms that will organize people to
scale down back scaling down
individually is very hard right imagine
you go to a place everybody's dressed
nicely you're the only one who doesn't
dress nicely everybody has you know gone
vacations to
great place you go to the Jersey Shore
it's very hard to do these things
without a organized mechanism but it
looks to me that there might be some
organized mechanisms
another interesting thing that is
happening in American society is that
people stop starting to talk about money
I don't know how you feel about this but
for a long time nobody was talking about
money it was a secret and it's kind of
very interesting because we do lots of
stuff to portray to other people how
much money we have it's the clothes we
wear and the cars we have in the house
they all kind of depict to other people
signal how much money we make but we
don't talk about it specifically and now
there's much more discussion about it
people are willing to say what are you
doing with your money what are you
saving what is happening and I'm
actually quite optimistic and that these
discussions might actually continue
because these discussions are about
social norms and once you break the
social norm and create a new social norm
of a sudden you can stay with us for a
long time
that's there's lots of psychological
problems with money money is a wonderful
invention
it lets us save it lets to specialize
right I couldn't be a professor if there
wasn't any money every day I would have
to raise chicken and bread and broccoli
and go ahead and spend all my time
trading so money is a wonderful
mechanism money is also very difficult
to think about so we think about money
is the opportunity cost of money so we
at some point went to a Toyota
dealership and we asked people what will
you not be able to do in the future if
you bought this Toyota now you would
expect people to have an answer but
people had were kind of shocked by the
question they never thought about it
before so the most we got was people
said oh if I can't buy this Toyota if I
buy this earth I can't buy a Honda so
they were making a substitution from the
same product in the same time but in
reality this is not a substitution their
subsidy summing for the future in the
future I will have to give up two weeks
of vacation and seventy lattice and 1500
books I don't know what exactly the
translation is but when we do consume
something now something else has to give
at some point what is this thing what is
this shadow value of price very hard to
think about it so that's a huge
psychological barrier so we're actually
trying to develop an iPhone app now that
the droid is out we'll do it for that as
well if we ever learn how to program on
this thing but the idea is that to make
money concrete so you come to this app
and it's not out there but you come to
the app and you say I like vacation in
the Bahamas shoes letters and books and
now when you're tempted to buy something
that thing translates in terms of the
things you're interested in so I said
hey this particular item is like half a
day in the Bahamas two shoes and one
latte which one of those is better now
in reality we think that comparing
everything to money is great but the
reality is that it's very hard to think
about money it's so general it's so
abstract that we don't really know what
we're giving up in what we're gaining so
if I gave you now $10 as a gift how
happy would you be would you be happy as
the module $10 the best use of $10 that
you can use of course not if I gave you
a CD you know exactly what you're
getting and you'll have an adoring crowd
so money has kind of lots of problems
with it
with money we really fool ourselves
something we are our biggest enemies
with money and there's some things we
can do about it automatic deductions are
a wonderful thing right ideally you
should wait until the end of the month
you can see how much extra money you had
and you should put that in your savings
account we don't do that well if we did
that we will never save so what we do is
we take money out of our pocket into a
saving account in the beginning of the
month
take it outside of our control and
there's a consequence we spend less and
save more this is by the way a very good
trick when you say if I realize my own
decision-making at every moment I will
fail many many times if I think once
very hard and create a standard of what
I want to do and create an automatic
execution that will take out the money
every month from my bank account then
there's good chance I'll behave better
not because I'm making good decisions
because it's making it for me
so I think automatic deductions are one
thinking about money in concrete terms
so when you come to think about buying
something usually we compare within
categories for example you go to a
restaurant you look at the wine list and
you never say to yourself my goodness
for the difference between these two
bottles of wine I could buy 3 gallons of
milk right we just don't think like this
we compare wine - wine and milk - milk
and beer - beer but in fact it's how we
want to think now it's very hard to do
it in an extensive way but when you face
something you could say what else could
I get if I didn't get this and which one
of those is giving me the greatest
pleasure now it's not always that we
always need to save more and spend less
I think the question is are we
allocating our money correctly across
into different categories money is a
great way to get happiness right lots of
wonderful things you can do with money
the question is are we really optimizing
on that so if you think about getting
lattice and getting cable which one of
those is actually giving your great
greater happiness and if you had to cut
on one of those which one would you
would you cut and so I think thinking in
terms of concrete in concrete terms
would would help us a great deal
there's another thing we call the pain
of paying
there's another idea called the pain of
paying this was proposed by George
Lowenstein and Rajan frelich and here is
the idea imagine that I own a restaurant
and imagine that I discover that people
come and they eat 50 bites and they pay
fifty dollars and one day I offer you a
great deal I said you know what today
could be half price 50 cents per bite
and moreover and only charge you for the
bites you take and you're going to sit
there and you're going to eat and I'm
going to sit there with your wallet and
every bite you take I'm going to take 50
cents from your wallet and transfer it
to my cash register now it's going to be
a very efficient way to eat because
you're not going to spend much money
cheaper plus all in the bites you eat
but how much fun will eating be not very
fun
right why because it turns out that this
simultaneity of eating and consuming or
enjoying and paying actually makes
things less happy here's another example
imagine you go on a cruise to Alaska and
you can either pay six months in advance
or the moment you get off the ship it's
much more reasonable economically to pay
the moment you get off the ship but how
much would you enjoy the last day of the
cruise it will be kind of miserable
knowing that tomorrow you have to pay
all this money so what happened is that
this simultaneity is very important and
we can use it in two ways we can think
about how we reduce the pain of paying
so for example credit cards are
wonderful mechanisms to reduce the pain
of pain if you go to a restaurant then
you pay in cash
you would feel much worse than if you
pay in a credit card why you know the
price there's no surprise but if you
find cash you feel a bit more guilt it's
a bit more difficult it's kind of more
painful to part with your money with the
creditors there it's another time so you
can think about this is good or bad if
you want to spend more money in
restaurants use credit cards more than
cash if you want to spend less use cash
more than modern credit cards but in
general we can think about how to use
the pain of paying and how much if we do
we want and I think we have like a range
credit cards have very little pain of
paying debit card have a little bit more
because you feel like today at least
it's coming out of your checking
and cash has much more but you can even
do better than cash imagine that you had
envelopes and your envelopes were
telling you how much money you have in
each category for the for the rest of
the month you had an envelope for coffee
you had an envelope for restaurants you
had an envelope for grocery now when you
take money out you also see how much
what you have left is shrinking and that
would actually increase the pain of
paying more now I don't think we should
go around life and being miserable all
the time and feeling the pain of pain
it's a question of what categories we
want to spend more on and what
categories we feel that we're spending
too much on and we want to cut down
so part of the problem is the dropping
the buckets problem right so if I don't
have money for health insurance which is
$5,000
what will five dollars today be and
that's a problem for Christine nation
it's $5 today and today and today the
problem is we can't envision to
ourselves how this money would would
accumulate we have to see where it's
coming from and I think we need
visualizing tools I think actually the
bank's role is to help us think about
money better and sadly nobody is doing
it because everybody wants us to spend
more and more I was actually getting a
little bit optimistic when the recession
hit because banks were becoming
interested in getting people to be more
responsible but but sadly I don't see
this happening these days that there are
a couple of startups a couple of ideas
kind of roaming around and I hope there
will be some some progress but if you
think about a person who is facing this
dilemma it's not humanly possible for
him to think about the compound interest
in the long-term ramifications of a
lotta a day we need help in that and I
hope that software will provide this
help I also think that the phone is a
wonderful idea for that if you think
about you all have good intentions even
your friend who is spending their five
day on the lot and they have good
intentions for the long term only that
in the short term it's very hard to act
on these good intentions and the phone
is interesting because it can be with us
when we have long term plans and when we
have short term failing and if you think
about the phone is a time machine in
this case I think it could help you
I'll tell you one more application this
is the first app we're going to have out
we'll have have it up I hope in two
weeks if you know Apple Larry approves
and you go on day on the iPhone and you
pick for people that you admire that you
respect and you pick them from your
address book and then when you tempt it
with something you say what you tempted
with and then you pick one of those
people and you say what will they have
told me to do now what's the idea there
the idea is that when we are in a
situation it's very hard for us to take
the outside perspective but if we say
what would your mother tell you to do
and then you you click on tempted to buy
coffee I'm picking my mother what would
I rather tell me and I think my mother
will tell me no and then it also sends
it to your mother to verify now you
don't have to wait for your mother to
verify to figure it out but here is to
give people the outside perspective get
them to think a little bit about as
advisors to themselves and what we find
not in this app but in general in in
experiment is that when people take the
role of advisors they become more
rational they see the long term or in
the short term they are less committed
to the emotion of the moment and they
could do better now we have one solution
I don't think so I think we'll have lots
of solutions but I think we're kind of
at the start of developing some software
some pre-commitment devices some more
awareness and I'm actually optimistic
that we will become better and better at
this
there's another question about how
people decide what loans to pay first so
we're assuming right now in this
discussion people have money and it's a
question of saving versus spending what
happens to people who have lots of loans
so we recently did a study that asked
the question of how do people decide
what loans to pay first and sadly what
we found out is that people paid these
small loans before they pay the big loan
so imagine you have six loans small to
huge people want to close loans and
because of that they they pay off they
try to pay off the small loans but
that's not the right strategy the right
strategies of course to pay the longer
the highest interest rate people make
this mistake and it cost them lots and
lots of money it's a very expensive
mistake because interest rates are
accumulated and become very very
expensive very quickly
we also found in our experiments that
too many people these days when they
have cash they keep too much cash in
reserve and it actually looked like a
stew two-stage process people decide how
much cash to keep kind of for a rainy
day and then the rest they allocate
between loans and all the time they
learn a little bit about how to allocate
the loan so that they pay first the big
the big the high interest rate they
don't learn perfectly but a little bit
but they still keep paid too much in
cash and interestingly these two
mistakes are connected the people who
keep more cash also turn to be more
mistaken in how they allocate loans and
this is I think a couple of really big
mistakes first of all people should
figure out very quickly how to pay loans
fast and they should do it well because
it's so expensive to have loans the
second thing is I think that this a time
in history mu is so uncertain about
everything and everybody gives us advice
about keep six months salary in cash
this is good advice to some people but
it's not good advice for people who have
loans because if you have loaned the
first thing you want to do is to say
look I have a credit card if I really
need to borrow I have this emergency
money that I can I can get but for now
there's no reason for me to keep cash at
0% interest rate and at the same time
pay all of this all of this money out so
I think people need to figure out
quickly how to pay loans and how much
cash they should really keep
so I was
forever basically I was in grad school
for seven almost seven years I got two
PhDs in the process but I was addressed
in for a long time and I got used to the
lifestyle of a grad student and when
when I finished and I moved to Boston we
moved to Boston the biggest mistake I
did was that I was so used to living on
a PhD student salary that I couldn't
stomach the idea of getting getting an
apartment in the size that would
actually be good for us so the problem
is we we moved from North Carolina to
Cambridge for the first two months we
couldn't believe these were the prices
of houses right we were used to paying
North Carolina prices they were taking
us to all these things with for sure
they're hiding something these are kind
for tourists right tourist traps took us
two months to realize what what the
price that really were of houses and we
could have afforded something that would
be reasonable for us but but I couldn't
bring myself to that I couldn't bring
myself for that and we ended buying an
apartment it was too small it was great
for us when we were a couple but very
quickly we had we had the kid and then
we had to move and this was of course
the transaction cost of moving
apartments it was very high so if I only
could stomach early on to buy a bigger
place we wouldn't have had to do this
double double move and the other thing
that has happened recently is this look
I I have to say that this financial
recession has been very good for my
field right for a long time we would say
all people are irrational they make
mistakes and people say oh I see acses
these are undergrads who make mistakes
professional people who get paid a lot
of money in a competitive environment of
the marketplace will never make this
mistake so all of a sudden we were
vindicated and we have a heyday my book
is doing where all right people invite
me to give talks life is quite good on
on this side it's no consolation for
anything but you know at least somebody
is benefiting from this and and when the
recession hit for the first time in ten
years
we decided to go on vacation now we'd go
on vacation with night numbers we always
go to see family we go to see my family
in Israel on my wife's Emily in India we
don't really do vacation vacation just
just awesome we decided to go on
vacation and we decided just when the
recession kind of hit and in the reality
is that vacations became cheaper we
could have gone to a great vacation to
do it but we also felt very guilty
spending the money the uncertainty the
questions about it all of it was very
confusing and we really felt better now
the reality is we were doing okay we
have a long time until retirement
whatever we lost in the stock market
doesn't really come to play for another
30 years we've tenured track you know
we're tenured professors that the odds
that we would lose our job is very low
from all the people in the world we're
relatively secure in our jobs but
nevertheless we felt bad about it and we
kind of downgraded our vacation to a big
to a big degree and it was great I mean
we had a great time but but we should
have done the other thing we just felt
really guilty with this economic
recession and spending money on vacation
so so let's kind of rewind the clock for
a second and think about what happened
when the gas prices reach four dollars
it was incredible right it was amazing
how concerned people were in fact I was
on the radio show with somebody who was
bought an Escalade you know a Cadillac
Escalade one of these huge cars eight
months earlier he bought this car when
the price of gasoline was 320 and he was
back at the dealership when the price
hit four dollars to trade it in and he
bought it for 74 thousand dollars and
they're offering him thirty five
something like that now this is a huge
loss that he was going to good now on
that day everybody was afraid of big
cars and everybody want to turn them
back and nobody wanted to buy them it
was the worst time from a supply and
demand perspective to sell a gas guzzler
and that wasn't funny I said wait don't
do it it's the wrong thing how many
years will you have to drive from a
financial perspective how many years
will you have to drive with this to
justify it now it's true that price of
gasoline increase by 80 cents since you
bought the car but they were very
expensive when you bought it and you
decide to buy it now just to be clear I
don't want people to drive gas guzzlers
and so on
but this guy was going to lose a
tremendous amount of money not to
mention it was going to buy a new car
for this and the question was why were
people so concerned now I went back home
and I looked at kind of my personal
finances and I discovered that the way
that gasoline prices affected my
personal life in terms of how much I was
spending a year on it was really quite
marginal compared to how much my health
care cost has increased but nobody seems
to care nobody seems to be shouting over
this and even the gas even energy prices
at home gas and electricity have gone up
dramatically but it was the pump that
got people so approach now why I think
there two reasons one is that we all
have this ideology of gas should cost $1
per gallon from whenever in the past and
the second thing is we see it all the
time I mean do you even know how much a
kilowatt hour is costing you it's hard
it's hard to tell because we don't see
it but you stand next to the pump you
fill it up there's nothing else to do
and you watchin this number going up so
two things happen you know how much it
cost and you buy multiple units every
time imagine the same thing would happen
to bread you know last year when there
was the the oil crisis bread increased
dramatically my bakery basically had to
put the sign said I'm sorry but the
price of wheat have increased more than
200% recently but when we buy bread we
don't really remember how much it cost
last I mean we don't bright by 12 loaf
so 15 loaves at a time so so what is the
lesson from this about energy
consumption I think it's about salience
II that energy consumption when
something is salient is going to be very
painful to us guilt invoking and we were
going to try and do things to overcome
it energy consumption it is hidden and
we don't see it's not going to matter so
much so now the question is what do we
do with electricity at home how do we
get people to think more carefully now
you can imagine that you can use the
same metaphor you can imagine you can
get people engage in their home they'd
show them at every moment how much
energy they're using you can imagine
that when they use another instrument at
home it shows them how much they could
have used and how much they're using
right now and how much the difference is
costing them or even worse would custom
it retirement with compound interest so
linking these financial elements to
energy consumption I think has a huge
has a you draw if you think about a
display instrument that could teach us
about what we're using how much it cost
us how much it is saving and and
therefore change our decisions so you
know do you know how much money you
would save if you change your light bulb
to compact fluorescent light bulbs you
know how much would you save if you
decrease your temperature in your house
in the in the winter by one degree or
increase it by one degree and we just
don't know these numbers but I think
this place could make it a memorable
salience in terms of attention and also
help us translate it in terms of
concrete ways on what you could get look
if you keep on doing this this way you
could get two days in the Bahamas next
time you go on vacation